brrra
brRrRrRa
*explosion*
Welcome to Youtube's favorite show
Skratta duUuUu
förlorar du Mannen
maAnNEn!!
MAANNEN
cameraman: you stupid
kid: no I'm not
cameraman: whats 9+10?
LEBRON JA-
LEBRON JAAAAA
*inhale*
Lebron jahahmes
so far, have not laughed (ZERO DEATHS)(Totally not true but eh)
How bout you? leave a sp - s - like down in the comments.
so I can know if you liked or laughed.
Straight guy, James Charles (old tea, new taste.)
What's the matter?
Scared you might like it?
subscribe to hannah kim levy
(This isn't funny I am laughing at my reflection) (Why is it funny?)
Oh that was hard I almost laughed at that one.
*mumbles* the f*ck (FRICK) happened to this show?
Big man Tom: hOW YOU DOIN INSTAGRAM IT'S BIG TIME TOMMY
HERE'S MY THOUGHT O' THE DAY
LIVE THE BEST LIFE YOU CAN (if you have one)
Thank you, thank you so much *cries in Gucci*
(trippin') How is this real??//??
Need some frickin' sUNSCREEN TOMMY
Haters will hate always
That's what they do :')
They hate.
BUT YOU KNOW WHAT
They hate themselves
tHeY haTE tHemSelVes (damn Tom u hit pewds in the feels)
h e y w a s s u p
Instagram (ad) it's your boy Tommy T
(That's a big cigar)
How ya doin' Instagram it's Big Time Tommy
*Laughs in not laughing/tots not laughing*
Something to remember, something to carry you through this day, so far no skratta du.
I gotta say, so far no skratta. Isn't that right Felix?
(just had a skratta- STILL ZERO DEATHS)
GOT EM
what is this?
Austrailia
I love you Henry, that's nice.
*still not laughing. Not skratta*
*What does Cyka Blyat mean*
*Little skratta*
They still want- they're not gonna settle down until I give them Major, I guess. I can't do that.
Well played Australia, well played, that was beautiful.
Here, this is for you.
Me?
Nonono for him
Oh him?
*Why is Felix laughing so hard, its not that funny?*
(omg ikkk)
GOT EM
I love that, you're out with your girl; [and] she accepts a rose from a random stranger.
No, it's for you.
Brofist, that's epic.
That's a gamer moment.
(we love sonic pr0n)
(It sounds kinda like a human/cow mooing at a scared child?)
(I really don't know what's happening.)
I think we can all relate, I think we've all been there.
No judgement passed from this guy at least.
IS DAT SONIC???
BELLE DELPHINE SONIC?
ok.. ok.. ok.... i'm not hating!
i'm not hating...
*flips skateboard*
WOOOOOAH!
(;-;  reminds me of Slippy)
WOOOOAAAAAAHH!
Holy s*it it's like airbug
but instead of a dog it's a tOAd
and instead of bASkETBaLL
its SKAtboaRdiNG
wat da hell man
the frog is more skate-cllah than I ever will
it's like the new tony
*tony hawk more like tony--
.................................
frAAhG
*cuts to credits but not really*
hey more James Charles memes everyone
"James Charles trying to seduce straight
men into hooking up with him"
vid: pLEaSe
nO cHOwDER
prETTy plEEEEZ?
WAT THE--
*pewds chuckles*
oh god...
anime girls smiling with their eyes
closed are so cute
hey look it's Poppy Gloria (uwu)
she is so adorable
too bad she's living on the
streets now thanks to you guys and your
cancel c*nt culture. Disgusting
*music*
oh stop
stOOOp
sTOP
you ain't cute
okay, you ain't cute and no one think
you cute no no no you look stupid
*music resumes* (she trying too hard)
wat is dis?
heh heh heh heh
*pewds chuckles*
I leave TikTok for a week and this is
what you come up with?
oh my god
what has happen-
what has happening
AAHHH
ah thank God it's over
*pewds laughs*
dan't nah f*cking stay around my house all day
go teh f*ck, go
go find
a f*cking job
ya fu*kin sausage roll lookin' tw--*bleeped*
noo-oooo
oh heh ooooo
don't hurt himmm
poor thang stAAAP that
he can't hAAALLLp it
fat dog can't even get a job
what is this?
I've got three tens which
is thirty and five ones
so that is 30
plus 5
12 is one 10--
heh heh
you know people did the
teachers did this in school like this is
so much easier if you do it like this
and it's just the most elaborate thing
to ever remember that no one's ever
gonna use as well
okay so that's step one
why's there a dog crying in the background? "now draw a large box"
she's teaching a dog how to do math?
*laughs very loudly at his joke*
okay and on this box we're gonna put
both of our expanded number--
oh my god
waman: so on the top, I'm gonna put 30
plus 5
and you know the teacher forces you to use his
method too like if you didn't show that
you did her method in the test you
wouldn't get like the grade or whatever
and on the side I'm gonna put 10+2
where your plus signs are I want you to draw a line
through the middle
pewds: oh my god
waman: and down it and then in the very corner--
how long does this go
--a big multiplication sign
starting with our very first number on the top
pewds: thirty-five times twelve you take(x3)
you take thirty times ten... no wait..
how would I do this
now you take 35 times ten and then you
you plus seventy...
three hundred fifty... plus seventy
it's 420 (pewds is a math genius!!! 👏👏)
four twENtAYYYY
OOOOOOOOHHHHHHHHH
*explosion*
*knocking sound*
*loud clash*
pewds: NOOO
*video repeats*
nOOO
you can't snap your fingers
inside your mouth
*pewds tries lol*
*succeeds once*
AHhhh!
you already did this in the video getting old....
VIDEO: ah oh you f*cking
you won't do it (x2)
lemme just go like this and see if..
if it connects to thaa--
*screams*
PEWDS: Oh Jesus! Oh Jesus
hahahaha
*clip repeats*
a millimeter away actually let me just
make go ahead and make sure the--AAHHH so
I was playing Minecraft and trying to
build a house and I forgotten that I had
Nicolas Cage texture pack then it
started raining and I freakin screamed
hey hey hey hey
I would die for you!
AWWWWWW
you awww you lose, and I guess I just lost
VIDEO: somebody help him like why you f*cking recording?
B*tch cause I don't work here (in background: exACtlY)
YOU work here
Help 'em!
the f*ck you mean?
dumbass
VIDEO: somebody help him like why you f*cking recording
B*tch I don't work here (in background: exACtlY)
YOU work here
Help 'em!
the f*ck you mean?
dumbass
dUMMY
PEWDS: so much nicer to see people have empathy
and caring for each other, helping each other
*in another language*
(So how ya'll doing? doing good ya know :3 this clip is really cool uwu)
Pewds: What?
oh my god what is...
what is that?!?
how does that even wORk!?
*startling noise*
WOAH
they're summoning the jeans from the
nebLAH RROOOO
OH MY GOD
*electrical buzzing*
OHHHHHHH OH!
*sounds like creepy chanting* (they're summoning the jeans!)
OH. MY. GOD!
Take off your jeans right nOW
you could be possESSed!
is it weird that I kind of want to lay in front of that laser?
and just become jeans (YOU'LL JUST GET BURNED)
Can you imagine how awesome that would be?
That you can be your jeans. (this should seriously be a pewdiepie quote)
PewDiePie jeans...
Random guy: Oh shi*iiit
Pewds: What is this clip
It's everywhere
*block breaks*
*throws shoe*
stAAAAp
ah goddammit
I don't want to alarm you, but--
*phone alarm goes off*
goddamn it memes are so bad right now, we
need a good meme guys please it's just
please anything but this
say at least that I can appreciate
a funny creative edit
Welcome to Arby's would you like to try one of our
*incoherent*
today?
*too mixed up to understand*
BRAH
*all laugh*
Da fuk--
Pewds: HA
Just ask for a water.
That'll be it.
*Pewds laughing*
Pewds: alrighty water coming right up
they should have all said in unison that
would have been so great
I don't know what I'm doing
*All Screaming (and swearing)* (yo is RDJ ok??)
WAT DA FUK
AHHHHHH!
Pewds: oh god that's great all right they
picked up a bit, they picked up a bit
I may have been skratting just a little
bit (nah u did, A LOT but like ZERO DEATHS)
Whaa-huh is this?
HAMBURGER
STAAP GODDAMMIT
sTOP with a hamBURGeR please
*prays* please!
I need a good 👏Meme Review👏
no hamburger please i can't do it
AH
So, that's another episode of
skrattar du förlorar du
hope you guys had fun
I said I hope you
guys had
fUN
Roll the outro !
(Brad-Madlad-Moment.mp3)
(BUT CAN YOU DO THIS???)